wir reden über das Wort Blackout seit
langem das ist das große angstwort für
diesen energiekrisen Winter was passiert
wenn der Blackout kommt ja dann gehen
wenn der Strom lange weg ist die
gefängnistora auf das steht genau so in
Berliner Notfallplan der Bild vorliegt
Blackout Knackis raus denn den
Notstromversorgung reiche je nach Knast
maximal 21 bis 100 Stunden das bedeutet
also Türen auf konkret langzeitausgänge
für bestimmte Gefangene und das bis zu
mehreren Tagen die gehen auf andere
Gefangene sollen gar entlassen werden
darüber sprechen wir mit dem Chef der
Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft mit Rainer
Wendt der uns zugeschaltet ist schönen
guten Tag erwähnt also mann oh mann so
Notfallplan der soll ja eigentlich
beruhigen aber dieser Notfallplan
Blackout und Knackis frei beruhigt mich
nicht
es ist ja auch nicht der einzige
Notfallplan aber die gute Nachricht
dabei ist es gibt schon mal einen Plan
das heißt Politik ist darum bemüht
sowohl im Justizvollzug aber auch bei
Polizei bei Spezialeinheiten in vielen
anderen Bereichen sich endlich einmal
auf eine Notfallsituation vorzubereiten
das haben wir ja in der Pandemie ganz
anders erlebt da wurde erst monatelang
beschwichtigt verharmlost
heruntergeredet und lange Zeit galt auch
derjenige der von einem Blackout auch
nur gesprochen hat als Spinner als
Verschwörer und das hat jetzt
mittlerweile aufgehört das heißt Politik
bereitet sich konkret auf solche
Einsatzsituationen vor und dass sie
natürlich sehr vielschichtig sind und
nicht nur sämtliche Bereiche des
Privatlebens berühren sondern auch und
gerade die öffentliche Verwaltung das
liegt auf der Hand und solche Pläne
zeigen jetzt vor allem wie schwach der
Staat im Grunde genommen aufgestellt ist
wir beklagen das ja als Gewerkschaft
seit vielen Jahren dass man auch für
solche Notfallsituationen besser als
bisher gerüstet sein muss und solche
Pläne offenbaren es dass es tatsächlich
auch eine Gefahr dabei gibt wobei ich es
nicht ganz so dramatisch sehe wie sie es
vielleicht eben dargestellt hat nehmen
wir mal an es würde wirklich zum Worst
Case Szenario kommen also dass die
Gefängnistore aufgehen was würde denn
dann mit den Insassen passieren wo kein
Mini dann hin was müssen die dann in
Zukunft befürchten oder wenn die dann
einfach wieder frei nein es gibt ein
sehr abgestuftes Programm man muss sich
ja immer auch vorstellen wo fällt der
Strom aus wenn er beispielsweise in
Anführungsstrichen nur in Berlin
ausfallen sollte käme beispielsweise
eine Verlegung von Gefangenen in andere
Bundesländern betrachten das ist ja auch
tägliche Praxis man nennt das ja
verschoben dass die Gefangenen von einem
Gefängnis ins andere gebracht werden
dann würde man wenn man überhaupt zu
Entlassungen käme natürlich nicht
diejenigen entlassen von denen eine
Gefahr ausgibt ausgeht es gibt ja auch
solche die beispielsweise
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafen dort absitzen und
das würde die würden dann möglicherweise
zu einem späteren Strafantritt wieder
geladen möglich wäre auch ein
verlängerter Hafturlaub bei denjenigen
die sowieso Hafturlaub genießen von Zeit
zu Zeit und deshalb auskommen das heißt
eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung sollte
ja grundsätzlich vermieden werden
Personen von denen wirklich große Gefahr
ausgeht die würden auch nicht in
Freiheit entlassen werden aber ist das
nicht irre vor einigen Wochen wäre man
noch verhauen worden dafür wenn man
gesagt hätte dass so ein Blackout ja
dann gefährlich ist auch für die
öffentlichen Behörden auch für
Krankenhäuser für Gefängnisse und so
weiter wenn wir gesagt wurden ja im
moment mal wir haben doch Generatoren
und das ist doch alles abgesichert und
jetzt Stück für Stück sehen wir nee nee
dass das schaffen wir gar nicht viele
Städte sind gar nicht ausreichend
ausgerüstet mit Generatoren wir haben
das als Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft
immer wieder gesagt dass man die Dinge
nicht verharmlosen soll rein technisch
ist es natürlich möglich mit Benzin und
mit Diesel auch Strom zu versorgen aber
dazu braucht man halt Treibstoff dazu
braucht man die Generatoren und aber vor
allen Dingen auch einen Plan die Dinge
die jetzt elektronisch dieser dieser
vielen Jahren die selbstverständlich
laufen dann sozusagen mit der Hand zu
machen und was man auch braucht und das
hat man nun einmal sträflich
vernachlässigt in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten ist das Personal denn wo
jetzt ein Notrufknopf um mal ein
praktisches Beispiel zu sagen wo jetzt
ein Notrufknopf in einer
Justizvollzugsanstalt aufleuchtet
leuchtet dann demnächst gar nichts mehr
auf das heißt wir müssen mit Personal
überall in den Fluren in den Gängen
präsent sein um bei Notfällen auch
schnell eingreifen zu können und das ist
die Koks die die Telefonsysteme brechen
zusammen dafür braucht man Funkgeräte in
Berlin scheint man dafür gerüstet zu
sein aber man sieht jetzt wie schwach
der Staat im Grunde genommen aufgestellt
ist aber noch einmal die gute Botschaft
ist endlich fängt man an zu arbeiten an
solchen Plänen und zwar nicht nur in
Berlin sondern in ganz Deutschland die
Justizminister der Länder haben sich
daran gesetzt sich auf diese Situation
vorzubereiten und hoffen wir dass diese
Situation noch mal Eintritt das ist das
erste und hoffen wir vor allen Dingen
dass die Justizminister aus diesen
Plänen jetzt einmal lernen und sehen wie
schwach der Staat aufgestellt ist und wo
die Notwendigkeiten sind den Staat zu
stärken sowohl in der Technik als aber
auch und vor allem beim Personal keiner
wenn Chef Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft
bei Bild live sagt man hat die Situation
in Deutschland mal wieder unterschätzt
vielen Dank
[Musik]